all right everybody it's Warren and we
have some really really big news about
Marvel's official reveal of phase four
we have an official statement from
Disney saying that we're going to get a
peek at the exciting upcoming slate of
Marvel Studios as projects and films so
we'll jump right into it but first a
quick reminder about my giveaway at the
450,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and each will get
to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection all you have
to do to enter is be subscribed to my
channel like the video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
has publicly said that Marvel will be
attending San Diego comic-con this year
in 2019 and he also publicly stated that
we're not going to be getting any
information about phase four until after
the release of spider-man far from home
so many people thought that we would be
getting the reveal for phase four at San
Diego comic-con this year however
according to Disney it looks like we'll
be getting a peek of phase 4 at their
event d23 now that doesn't mean that we
won't be getting anything at San Diego
comic-con but Disney has come out with a
statement that says we will be getting a
peek at the future flight of Marvel
Studios at their d23 event this will
happen Saturday August 24th at 10:00
a.m. this is Disney's official statement
of what to expect at their d23 event on
August 24th the Walt Disney Studios will
present a behind-the-scenes look at its
blockbuster collection of upcoming films
on Saturday August 24th at 10:00 a.m.
fans will see what's on the drawing
board for the acclaimed filmmakers at
Walt Disney Animation Studios and Pixar
Animation Studios and get a peek at the
exciting slate of live-action projects
from Disney to Marvel Studios to Star
Wars as always attendees will be treated
to exclusive footage special guest
appearances and more so there you have
it an official statement from Disney
stating that at the d23 event we will be
getting a peek at the exciting slate of
upcoming films from Disney to Marvel
Studios this will be our first official
reveal and look at Marvel Studios as
phase 4 of the MCU
we could get something at San Diego
comic-con but it does make sense
that Disney would reveal phase 4 at
their own event d23 for those of you who
are not aware of what d23 is it's
Disney's biggest event that they have
every two years so since Disney is doing
their d23 event this year they didn't do
it last year and they did not attend San
Diego comic-con last year which means we
are going to get some big news at this
year's d23 and as its stated in Disney's
official statement we are going to get a
peek at the upcoming exciting slate for
Marvel Studios Marvel has already
announced their upcoming movie release
dates for the next three years and we
have a pretty good idea of what movies
are going to be coming in phase four
however Marvel does have a tendency to
surprise us so it's going to be super
exciting at Disney's d23 event this year
where we will officially find out about
Marvel's phase four so let me know how
excited you are to finally see an
official reveal of the future of the MCU
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again don't
forget about my giveaway at the 450,000
subscriber mark I will be picking three
winners and each winner will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection I will also be
starting giveaways on Instagram and
Twitter soon if you want to follow me on
social media as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
relations to your desperation to save
the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very Nass and
all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your